some congressional Democrats compared
President Trump to Richard Nixon who
ordered the firing of the Watergate
scandals independent prosecutor Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer talked to
the President on the phone Schumer says
he told the president he was making a
big mistake mr. Trump responded in a
tweet that said Schumer stated recently
quote I do not have confidence in Comey
any longer then act so indignant Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where leaders
from both parties are reacting Nancy
good morning good morning this move
created quite a bit of alarm on Capitol
Hill including among some Republicans
like Arizona's John McCain who renewed
his call for an independent
congressional Commission to look into
Russia but Democrats no question are
going much farther than that saying the
only thing that will work now is a
special prosecutor some of them even
describing this as a constitutional
crisis it was brazen one of the most
staggering stunning acts of a present
compromising and investigation Democrats
savaged the president's decision calling
it Nick Sounion mind-boggling and a
cover-up if there were any question
about the need for a special prosecutor
there is none now Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer accused the Trump administration
of systematically silencing law
enforcement leaders who cross them
they fired Sally Yates they fired Preet
Bharara
and now they fired director Comey the
very man leading the investigation this
does not seem to be a coincidence
some Republicans were scathing to
Arizona's Jeff Flake said on Twitter
I've spent the last several hours trying
to find an acceptable rationale for the
timing of commis firing I just can't do
it but other Republicans like Lindsey
Graham argued the FBI needs a fresh
start after Comey got tangled up in the
2016 campaign the investigation is going
forward both at the FBI and in the
Senate Intelligence Committee
in a bipartisan way and yet the
Republican chair of the Senate
Intelligence Committee said commis
dismissal further confuses an already
difficult investigation Comey was
scheduled to testify tomorrow is he
still going to attend I doubt if he'll
attend on Thursday but is still my
strong desire to have now former
director Comey come and testify before
the committee that's Senator Mark Warner
he is the top Democrat on the Senate
Intelligence Committee he and chairman
birth Comey as recently as Monday and by
all accounts Comey has been very
accessible to Congress on this Russia
investigation which is a big part of the
reason that Democrats are so sorry to
see him go even though they believe
Charlie that his handling of the Clinton
investigation contributed to her loss
thanks Nancy